[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue heureux de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle semaine de sens public vous
le savez la promesse et dans le titre de
l'émission donnée du sens à l'actualité
se mettre au service du public vous
proposez des clés de compréhension des
mutations de notre société avec deux
thèmes d'actu ce soir que l'on vous
propose la politique d'abord et
l'élection de Gérard Larcher un
cinquième mandat de président du Sénat
loi immigration vote du budget réformes
constitutionnelle sans oublier
d'éventuels commissions d'enquête la
chambre haute va peser sur le second
mandat d'Emmanuel Macron que promettent
ces nouveaux équilibres politiques
comment l'alliance GLR est des centrises
va-t-elle fonctionner et puis ce rapport
de force entre Gérard Larcher et
Emmanuel Macron va-t-il évoluer et au
bénéfice de qui on répond à toutes ces
questions dans une minute et puis pour
notre second débat d'actualité une autre
question le sort de la guerre en Ukraine
se joue-t-il
dans les bureaux de vote européen et au
Parlement américain la Slovaquie vient
délire un premier ministre pro russe qui
veut stopper les livraisons d'armes
nous sommes prêt à fournir une aide
humanitaire et à contribuer à la
reconstruction du pays mais vous
connaissez notre opinion sur l'armement
de l'Ukraine
aux États-Unis c'est la dernière
enveloppe de 22,7 milliards de dollars
qui est suspendu exclu de l'accord sur
le budget voté in extremis pour éviter
une paralysie de l'administration
américaine la lassitude gagne-t-elle les
opinions publiques démocratiques après
19 mois de guerre réponse dans 45
minutes mais d'abord donc cette journée
d'élection au Sénat Gérard Larcher
rempile pour trois ans sur le plateau le
surnom donné au siège de président
Cécile si
alors ce sont des choses qui arrivent je
suis en train de m'asseoir on a pas de
son sur le sujet de Cécile Sixou je vais
vous présenter mes invités en avant en
attendant peut-être que entre temps le
son sera arrivé à Charlène Bezin à
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
constitutionnaliste je vais vous faire
un aveu pendant que je vous ai mes
titres je savais que c'était très très
Ricard pour avoir le le sujet de Cécile
Sioux parce que le discours de de Gérard
Larcher c'est terminé il y a finalement
assez peu de temps cette fin
d'après-midi quand on prend l'antenne
bref on n'est pas là pour vous raconter
ce qui se passe dans notre cuisine
j'accueille Florent va dire au bonsoir
et bienvenue vous êtes président de
l'étheris cercle de réflexion qui a pour
objet de produire de diffuser une
réflexion de gauche sur l'ensemble des
sujets qui structure la vie politique
française et vous êtes enseignant à
Sciences Po Jean-Sébastien Ferjoux
bonsoir et bienvenue bonsoir vous êtes
directeur de la publication d'Atlantico
Guillaume d'arrêt bonsoir bonsoir Thomas
heureux de vous retrouver première sur
votre nouveau plateau merci beaucoup
sympa vous êtes éditorial de vous avoir
ici évidemment alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait est-ce qu'on a un son de Gérard
Larcher pour lancer ce débat allez on
écoute Gérard Larcher le président du
Sénat ancien nouveau qui s'est peut-être
futur président du Sénat bref c'est son
cinquième mandat à la tête de la chambre
haute et il s'est voulu encore et
toujours le porte-parole des territoires
on l'écoute
nous portons la voie des territoires
convaincu que la gouvernance verticale
la suradeministration
l'hyperconcentration du pouvoir soit en
partie à l'origine des mots dont souffre
notre pays nous devons remettre les mers
au cœur de la décision gérer en
proximité
imposer un nouveau souffle
de décentralisation mais à
décentralisation forte il faut un état
territorial fort nos collectivités ont
besoin de plus de liberté c'est vrai
pour les communes c'est vrai pour les
départements c'est vrai pour les régions
il nous faudra trouver un juste
équilibre entre différenciation et
unités de la République allez on ouvre
le débat c'est quoi pour vous le
principal défi de Gérard lâché pour ce
cinquième mandat
il y en a beaucoup c'est d'arriver à
gouverner un sénat qui a glissé un peu
vers le centre et qui va être l'arbitre
de beaucoup de nouveaux défis je pense à
la réforme constitutionnelle la réforme
de la décentralisation dont il était
question dans le discours mais aussi la
loi immigration peut-être que Gérard
lacher en venant des LR aura aussi ce
défi d'uni de donner une unité à ce
groupe en tout cas de lui donner un son
une voix des défis GG comme on l'appelle
ici paraît-il on a déjà relevé beaucoup
mais je crois que voilà cette manière de
gouverner tout en faisant des
territoires tout en ayant quand même
aussi un petit peu de fermeté lui
réussit bien et donc a priori il y a pas
de problème pour que dans trois ans ça
soit encore la même chose oui c'est une
question qu'on pourra se poser la suite
pour pour Gérard Larcher Florent
vadillot il y a ces réformes
constitutionnelles promises par Emmanuel
Macron sur le Tommy de la Corse le
statut de la Nouvelle-Calédonie est-ce
que j'allais dire presque mécaniquement
ça accentue le pouvoir oui parce que le
Sénat dans chacune des révisions
constitutionnelles a toujours négocié
son soutien son accord à des
prérogatives supplémentaires pour le
Sénat ou pour les collectivités qui
élisent les sénateurs donc lorsque le
président de la République a ouvert ce
chantier constitutionnel un peu malgré
lui en Nouvelle-Calédonie encore pour le
coup c'était totalement de son seul fait
il a des facto placés Gérard lacher dans
une position qui est de négociateur en
chef et pour à la fois les intérêts du
Sénat mais également contre les intérêts
de la majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
donc c'est un équilibre qui va être
compliqué à trouver et d'ailleurs dans
son discours
d'intronisation si je veux dire Gérard
Larcher a repris les anciennes qu'on
connaît c'est mais la différenciation le
pouvoir des collectivités l'unité de
normative donc c'est un peu un programme
de de révision constitutionnelle en tout
cas il marque quelles sont ses désirs et
quelles sont ses lignes rouges
Jean-Sébastien affaire joue plus qu'un
veau qui est ou qu'un cioti est-ce que
Gérard Larcher est aujourd'hui l'homme
fort de la droite
il est par sa capacité peut-être à faire
vivre les gens ensemble et par sa
position institutionnelle c'est le
troisième personnage de l'État et comme
ça vient d'être dit oui le Sénat dans la
mesure il n'y a pas de majorité absolue
à l'Assemblée nationale le Sénat a un
poids plus important dans la manière
dont son élaborer les lois et donc les
compromis potentiels sur X ou x projet
de loi comme on a pu le voir dans le
passé après genre à l'archer à aucun
moment n'a été véritablement la matrice
d'un renouveau idéologique on l'a
entendu là dans son discours finalement
d'ailleurs et vous faisiez référence aux
glissement de sa majorité vers le centre
la thématique de la décentralisation
elle est très chère au centriste bien
plus que au cœur des républicains
certainement donc on entend ça aussi
donc gérarchi oui il est incontournable
parce qu'il a la légitimité de sa
position institutionnelle mais comme je
vous le disais vous parliez de son futur
peut-être oui en 2026 pourra-t-il encore
être président du Sénat l'imagine ton
vraiment dans un rôle de renouveau qui
permettrait à la droite de s'imposer
dans une élection présidentielle je ne
m'en suis pas certain parce que c'est
certainement l'enjeu principal de la
droite aujourd'hui Florent vaillaud
parce que on dit l'homme fort d'une
droite faible ouais on pourrait on
pourrait rajouter ça à la phrase quoi
oui l'homme fort d'une droite faible qui
le premier a permis des compromis pas
seul mais des compromis avec la majorité
présidentielle parce que il y a une
division qui a été un peu accrue par les
sénateurs entre la les sénateurs
républicains et les députés républicains
donc il est l'homme fort d'une droite
faible mais d'une droite faible
sénatoriale parce que il a du mal à
calmer les troupes à l'Assemblée
nationale donc il y a un jeu de
diplomatie qui va être assez compliqué à
réaliser d'autant qu'Eric ciotine n'a
pas décidé de s'effacer et que un des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
sont déjà en train de voir le jour
c'est d'incarner une forme de permanence
dans un monde politique ou après
Emmanuel Macron on a vu beaucoup
d'anciens responsables politiques
notamment à droite disparaître du jeu
politique ce Saint-Nicolas Sarkozy Alain
Juppé François Fillon pour des raisons
diverses Gérard lâché il était là avant
Emmanuel Macron et finalement il sera
probablement là après Emmanuel mais
effectivement je reprends ce que disait
Jean-Sébastien
sa capacité à renouveler le la grille
d'analyse de la droite parce que c'est
ça l'enjeu des prochains mois c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt ça donne plutôt
l'impression vous savez c'est comme un
montagne quand l'accord des croches
finalement à droite ils ont tous
décrochés ils sont rattachés finalement
à Gérard lachet qui était encore qui
était encore là mais on ne voit pas
effectivement un renouveau idéologique
parce que pour l'instant il a plutôt été
quelqu'un qui a essayé de penser les
plaies de la droite mais il a pas
incarné une nouvelle pensée pour demain
et on disait qu'il y a quelques instants
je disais chez nos confrères du Figaro
que l'ancienne
Emmanuel mignon qui avait travaillé au
programme de Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007 et
qui avait été vu comme une des têtes
pensantes de ce programme qui avait été
salué à droite et qui est salué
aujourd'hui à droite comme finalement
l'un des derniers programmes
idéologiquement structuré va désormais
être chargé des études aux côtés
d'érections chez les républicains ça
montre bien quand même qu'effectivement
le renouveau idéologique de la droite
il se fait pas forcément ici au Sénat
avec Gérard lâcher et autrement il est
probablement voilà un homme fort dans un
contexte où la droite ou les LR en tout
cas sont plus un cartel électoral
qu'autre chose parce que quand vous êtes
un parti de notable finalement parce que
c'est ça et le Sénat par définition
représente ça bah vous êtes un parti qui
gère beaucoup de problématiques et c'est
très important il faut pas le mépriser
je ne lis absolument pas de manière
péjorative mais vous avez une vision
différente probablement de la vision de
celui qui se présente à une élection
nationale vous venez intervenir interdit
aussi que la capacité qu'il a à faire
qu'on s'insus puisque pour être présider
une assemblée ou les groupes sont aussi
hétérogènes qu'au Sénat avec des
identités aussi marquées on a le RDSE
qui est tellement particulier depuis
toute la Cinquième République et même
avant le Sénat a vraiment ses identités
à l'intérieur d'une même assemblée c'est
une capacité qu'il a de voilà de
finalement d'unir autour de son nom il
faut qu'il arrive à le faire avec les LR
de l'Assemblée nationale on en a déjà
parlé mais c'est vrai que réforme
constitutionnelle ou immigration il
faudrait déjà qu'ils arrivent à le faire
entre eux et lui sera peut-être aussi
pas forcément l'homme de la droite mais
l'homme des deux droites en fait de
celle de l'Assemblée et du Sénat parce
que c'est vraiment ça qui sera l'enjeu
avec un autre enjeu qui est la capacité
à résister
aux populismes aux extrémistes c'est ce
que disait tout à l'heure tient le doyen
de la haute assemble parce qu'évidemment
une soirée et une journée de d'élection
du président du Sénat il y a c'est très
ritualisé il y a le discours du Doyen en
écoute Jean-Marie vendre
face à cette menace
il nous faut me semble-t-il mobiliser en
priorité les élus locaux ceux qui sont
en première ligne ce que j'appellerais
l'armée de la République du quotidien
qui se sentent parfois incompris ou
délaissés et dont nous sommes ici les
représentants
le rôle du Sénat est donc plus que
jamais en tant qu'assemblée des
territoires de relever les défis qui
nous entourent
la fracture territoriale la perte
d'autonomie fiscale l'empilement des
normes la transition énergétique la
sécurité et j'en passe
je ne doute pas que la somme des talents
et de compétences d'expériences dans
notre assemblée renouvelée
apportera beaucoup à la fabrication de
la loi et à la résolution de ces enjeux
majeurs avec le courage de la nuance
dont parler Albert Camus bien loin des
facilités de outrance
le rôle du Sénat puisque jamais de
relever les défigments fractures
territoriales perte d'autonomie fiscale
empilement des normes transition
énergétique sécurité et j'en passe
unchainedina est-ce que le rôle du de la
chambre haute c'est privé Marine Le Pen
d'une partie de son argumentaire
politique c'est un peu ce que j'entends
dans cette tendance discours du Doyen
c'est un peu comme ça en tout cas qu'ici
on en a l'impression je Patrick canner a
dit aussi dans l'après-midi que incarner
une droite et une gauche au sein de cet
assemblée était une nouvelle frontière
contre ce populisme et contre les
extrêmes parce que c'est vrai que le
rôle du Sénat qui est la chambre de
représentation des territoires d'après
notre article 24 de la Constitution
c'est aussi de défendre une politique un
petit peu différente on l'a dit avec le
renouvellement du Sénat récemment il y a
une politique qui est beaucoup plus
ronde en fait qui vient moins être
frappé par les vagues de l'opinion et
évidemment le Sénat peut travailler sur
le fond peut prendre plus de temps et
peut aussi apporter un petit peu une
voix divergente par rapport au chaudron
du moment qu'elle Assemblée nationale où
on retrouve des groupes qui cherchent à
défendre leur identité au sein de voilà
au sein d'un Sénat beaucoup plus
bouillant que celui de du Sénat donc oui
je crois que les thèmes chers au Sénat
qui sont ceux de la localité qui sont
ceux de la vie du quotidien sont en
effet bien différents de ceux de
l'Assemblée nationale et qui a un pari à
jouer autour d'une voilà d'une politique
un petit peu plus incarnée ici
qu'ailleurs alors j'ai arraché réélu
président l'alliance de la droite et du
centre garde sa majorité bon ça c'est
pas des surprises tout le monde s'y
attendait alors évidemment c'est
intéressant parce que là les groupes ne
sont définitifs que demain à 16h donc on
va vous proposer un hémicycle qui par
définition n'est pas encore définitif
regardez on est à selon nos calculs à 17
communistes 17 écologistes 64
socialistes 15 RDS sera Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen 19 pour
RDPI on va dire avec principalement le
parti Renaissance 18 les indépendants
avec principalement le parti horizon 57
union centrices 133 LR quatre non
inscrits là dedans on compte les trois
sénateurs rassemblement national et un
reconquête et puis encore quatre
sénateurs qui ont pas choisi leur
destination on va en parler de ça mais
je propose à Steve Jourdain de nous
rejoindre ce qu'on va voir si ce Sénat
avec ses nouveaux ses équilibres
est devenu bonsoir Steve un peu plus
Macron compatible est-ce que le prix
dans la pub pour pouvoir s'appuyer sur
la la chambre pour faire passer certains
textes ce qui est sûr c'est que ce
scrutin des sénatorial était le dernier
scrutin national avant que tenez-vous
bien 2026 il y aura et bien le scrutin
des européennes en juin prochain et puis
rien pendant trois ans il y avait pas
mal de questions autour de ce fruit en
dessinateur est-ce que par exemple
Gérard Larcher pourrait et bien
éventuellement devenir un partenaire
pour Emmanuel Macron est-ce que le
centre pourrait se détacher de ses
alliés de la droite pour se rapprocher
de la macronie autant de questions que
ministre et député se poser jusqu'à la
semaine dernière Thomas est-ce qu'ils
ont eu des réponses oui mais performant
pas forcément celle qu'ils attendaient
on va rappeler le rapport de force qui
est sorti des yeux que vous l'avez un
peu montré juste avant la majorité de la
droite et du centre confirme sa
domination mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que la droite laisse des plumes au
profit notamment du centre il y avait
145 sénateurs LR avant le scrutin il
devrait être autour de 135 dans le dans
le nouveau scénario autour de 135 ça
pourrait être sans doute 132 on verra ça
demain dernier jour de mercato ici au
Sénat certains élus comme Darko
sénatrice de l'Essonne ou édouardiale
sénateur de l'Oise ont claqué la porte
pour rejoindre respectivement le groupe
des indépendants dirigés par Claude
malurey et le groupe Union centriste
présidé par Hervé Marseille est-ce
forcément une bonne nouvelle pour
Emmanuel Macron bah la grande affaire de
cette automne c'est la loi immigration
elle sera examinée au mois de novembre
les négociations entre gouvernement et
sénateurs ont déjà débuté objet des
tractations l'article 3 de cette loi qui
prévoit la régularisation des
travailleurs étrangers dans les métiers
en tension les élus LR on le sait ne
veulent pas de cette mesure ils estiment
qu'il s'agit d'une ligne rouge mais les
centristes eux sont prêts à négocier ils
sont plus d'une cinquantaine à la
Chambre haute et leur voix pourrait
compter au moment du vote pour Hervé
Marseille le président du groupe Union
centriste et bien l'heure n'est pas à
l'opposition stérile avec le président
de la République écouter le il s'agit
pas de d'être en opposition avec qui que
ce soit il s'agit simplement d'examiner
les textes de faire en sorte qu'il soit
viable pour être présenté à l'assemblée
et j'allais dire ce qu'il faut c'est
surtout être utile au pays et faire en
sorte que les textes qui ne soient
présentés et bien soit modifiés soit
travailler et voter comme on l'a fait
pour les retraites sur les migrations
Thomas l'exécutive joue très gros
puisque ça fait plus d'un an et demi
qu'on l'attend à cette loi immigration
pour sortir de la nasse le gouvernement
et bien pourrait contourner tout
simplement le vote des élus certains
éléments qui posent problème certains
éléments qui font des bas pourraient par
exemple passer par la voie réglementaire
c'est-à-dire par l'intermédiaire d'une
circulaire qui serait prise par le
ministère de l'intérieur c'est la risque
d'en faire bondir plus d'un ici au Sénat
merci beaucoup Steve Jordan pour toutes
ces explications on va évidemment
débattre autour de cette loi immigration
mais unchainedina un mot de ce qui va
aussi se jouer dans les prochains jours
sur
les ceux qui seront qui du siègeront en
commission mixte paritaire les vices
présidents parce que
cette hémicycle qu'on a vu du nombre de
de sénateurs qui se désignent dans tel
ou tel groupe dépend la suite de ces
événements expliquez-nous alors en effet
dans le droit parlementaire et ça avait
fait grand bruit après les législatives
parce que justement on avait tellement
de fragmentations des groupes que on
avait surveillé très près des organes
internes la composition du bureau les
vice-président etc et bien aujourd'hui
au Sénat en tout cas pendant toute la
semaine vont se dérouler des élections
internes pour ces organes représentatifs
alors c'est évidemment eux qui gèrent le
travail au quotidien le bureau par
exemple la composition du bureau les
vice-président les questeurs etc toutes
ces choses là doivent représenter c'est
le texte du règlement qui nous dit ça
les différentes nuances au sein de cette
Haute Assemblée donc on l'a dit les
équilibres on peut bouger mais peut-être
que de 1 ou 2 on peut arriver à faire
changer les équilibres un peu plus au
centre que ne l'était le Sénat avant
renouvellement donc cette ce
renouvellement des organes internes dira
quelque chose aussi de la manière dont
le Sénat va se concentrer et dont il va
être gouverné par ses organes internes
ce qui nous amène beaucoup de choses
dans le travail parlementaire au
quotidien
je crois que c'est bien sûr je suis
absolument d'accord avec tout ce qui va
être dit mais ça aura aussi un impact
peut-être sur la droite ou le visage de
la droite futur parce qu'on voit bien
qu'à droite maintenant pendant longtemps
il y avait la stratégie de dire nous
devons aller à la présidentielle de
manière absolument autonome et gagner en
étant dans l'opposition frontale et
Emmanuel Macron on voit que toute une
partie des républicains se disent que ça
n'est plus véritablement possible
notamment parce que reconquête
sociologiquement mort beaucoup sur leur
électorax c'est difficile d'imaginer un
candidat républicain qui parvienne à
être qualifiés pour un deuxième tour
donc ils se disent on va peut-être
Emmanuel Macron ne pouvant plus
représenter essayer de récupérer les
choses de l'intérieur ce qui était la
stratégie d'OPA sur sur la droite
macroniste ce qui était la stratégie
Nicolas Sarkozy sauf que probablement
c'était trop tôt puisque à l'époque les
députés LR avait été lu sur une ligne
très entier manuel Macron mais là on est
plus là et vous avez vu que Laurent
Wauquiez lui-même et dans une opposition
moins frontale qui ne l'a été dans le
passé et donc cette espèce de de
chaudron je sais pas de chaudron magique
visant à essayer de reconstituer une
droite un peu plus sur le centre droit
pourrait aussi ça a bien sûr un impact
sur le Sénat et sur la fin du
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron mais ça
pourrait aussi avoir un impact sur que
serait une droite ayant vocation à
reprendre la présidentielle enfin à
gagner une présidentielle justement dans
cette nouvelle configuration et flore on
va dire ça va d'abord se jouer là sur
cette loi immigration ça va permettre
finalement à la à la majorité
sénatoriale aussi de se compter ce bruit
c'est le premier texte c'est le texte
qui a le plus de d'arêtes politiques en
quelque sorte parce que il y a eu une
poussée de l'aile gauche de la macronie
dans Libération qui a tenté avec
d'autres responsables de gauche
principalement de demander sur les
métiers en tension on a vu des réactions
en de contrer en quelque sorte de la
part et puis on voit pas véritablement
la ligne sénatoriale se dessiner pour
l'instant parce qu'il y a eu des prises
de parents la c'est isolées Bruno
Retailleau est quand même allé
extrêmement loin sur un texte durci à
droite donc ce premier texte il vous
permettre effectivement de figer une en
tout cas une première stratégie une
première stratégie dans laquelle pour à
mes yeux pour l'instant les centrices
sont pas forcément les vainqueurs parce
qu'en réalité plus ils ont grossi ils
ont un peu grossi plus ils vont en
vouloir jouer le rôle de pivot mais plus
ils auront à leur gauche et à leur
droite des ailes qui pourront essayer de
réduire leur marge de manœuvre donc
avoir comment les centreres sont perçues
par les républicains et comment les
républicains peuvent faire des alliances
de revers parce que le Sénat est
toujours extrêmement propice à ce genre
d'alliance de revers on comprend pas
totalement comment se forge les
majorités mais à la fin ça tombe un peu
comme les sénateurs en train de se jouer
encore aujourd'hui avant je disais le
c'est demain 16h ou tous les sénateurs
ont dû choisir leur groupe là c'est pas
seulement des postes parce que ça ça
joue aussi on va pas être angélique il y
a aussi des postes qui sont promis mais
c'est aussi voilà le le contenu les
réformes à venir comment va se
positionner par rapport à ces réformes
très clairement il y a au moins trois
groupes qu'il faut regarder très
attentivement d'abord c'est le groupe de
Claude maluré parce que en réalité c'est
Édouard Philippe qu'on voit poindre
derrière donc le départ de Lord Archos
par exemple et de Courtial sont assez
symptomatiques pour celles c'était un
bébé Sarkozy quand même donc c'est un
premier indicateur il va y avoir le
groupe RDSE parce que pour le coup ça la
cheville elle est vraiment là il a un
peu diminué donc on va voir comment il
se positionne et puis il y a l'Union
centriste effectivement dont on verra
les contours c'est les trois groupes à
scruter parce que pour le reste c'est
que ça reste quand même assez lisible de
ceux qui vont s'inscrire ou pas dans les
groupes traditionnels Jean-Sébastien
Ferjoux cette loi immigration comment
vous la décrit est-ce que c'est devenu
un piège finalement pour Emmanuel Macron
et son ministre de l'Intérieur
en tout cas
on en parle qu'elle est dans les tuyaux
ils arrivent pas à la faire
politiquement certainement parce que la
manière dont elle a été présentée n'a
pour moi pas beaucoup de d'intérêt de
dire est-ce que parce que c'est
l'équilibre l'équilibre quelqu'un
incarné à l'Afrique Gérard Darmanin et
Olivier du soft c'est ça oui mais
vouloir à tout prix en faire un signal
et notamment de cette mesure sur la
régularisation comme si c'était une
appréciation de qui est droite ou qui
est plus de gauche Elisabeth borne veut
absolument essayer de maintenir une
disposition sur sur justement la
régularisation des travailleurs dans les
métiers en tension là où Gérard Darmanin
lui essaye plutôt de nouer en accord
avec la droite mais dans un cadre comme
dans l'autre est-ce que ça véritablement
du sens des préfère régularise déjà
chaque année justement des travailleurs
en tension donc ça c'est presque
méprisant j'ai envie de vous dire
vis-à-vis des personnes concernées parce
que c'est vraiment les prendre comme un
marchepied pour faire de l'étalage de
vertus politique selon qu'on veuille
afficher de la fermeté ou qu'on veille
afficher entre guillemets de l'humanité
et pour moi c'est véritablement un piège
un piège politique parce que quand vous
rentrez dans une logique qui n'est pas
celle de voter des lois qui ont vocation
à véritablement gérer la réalité de la
société française mais plutôt à gérer
les rapports de force au sein des partis
politiques je pense que c'est un
affaiblissement démocratique votre avis
d'être suffisant la parole juste après
vous êtes peut-être pas forcément
d'accord avec Jean-Sébastien Ferjoux
c'est est-ce que c'était un symbole qui
méritait de d'être inscrit dans la loi
puisque finalement c'est peut-être ce
qui va se passer on pouvait passer
effectivement par l'action des préfets
ou par le vote d'une circulaire d'abord
le loyer migration on a quasiment tous
les 18 mois en France donc évidemment
c'est pas nécessairement le changement
de paradigme qui recherchait c'est
l'affichage politique j'ai envie de dire
c'est un vecteur législatif qui n'a
presque que cette vertu là ce qu'on a
pas vu des modifications majeures
ensuite la question de savoir si on
pouvait passer par le droit le droit
enfin le règlement plus que par la loi
oui on peut toujours évidemment mais
après il y a des effets de bord qui sont
importants sur les métiers en tension en
réalité ce qui se joue derrière c'est la
première étape pour aller vers l'accord
provisoire de travail à l'allemande
c'est-à-dire qui permet de suivre les
personnes toute personne étrangères
rentrer sur le territoire mais est-ce
que c'est pas aussi une autre façon de
parler d'immigration dans notre pays
honnêtement je pense pas je pense que
véritablement on avait on a le débat
entre Elizabeth borne et Gérald Darmanin
entre l'aile gauche de la majorité et ce
qui est le droit de le monde a fait
fuité un indice créé d'Elizabeth borne
en disant que si Darmanin était premier
ministre elle constitue un groupe de 50
députés de l'aile gauche de la macronie
donc je pense qu'on a on est et Darmanin
a été premier ministre jusqu'au samedi
soir ou François Bayrou a donné a sonné
lalali donc je pense qu'il y a une vraie
rivalité sur sur la la cohérence de la
majorité mais il y a une vraie rivalité
mais encore une fois sans beaucoup de
contenu parce que résumé la rivalité à
cette mesure là ça ne dit pas ce qu'est
la gauche qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
avoir une sensibilité de gauche pour les
abeilles de bandes de manière générale
ou qu'est-ce que c'est la droite enfin
ça a pas beaucoup d'intérêt d'ailleurs
que d'autant que la droite est souvent
un revers là-dessus par rapport au chef
d'entreprise qui ont besoin dans un
certain nombre de cas de faire appel à
des travailleurs enfin qui n'ont pas de
papier tout simplement parce que sinon
ils n'ont pas d'autres solutions cette
nouvelle migration elle passe en
première lecture au Sénat uncharibusina
on l'a déjà évoqué ici mais qu'est-ce
que ça change pourquoi c'est important
c'est déjà une symbolique très forte
parce que
dans dans la grande partie des cas c'est
l'Assemblée nationale qui a cette
priorité directe et assez intuitive sur
tous les textes qui ne concerne pas
directement le Sénat ou les
collectivités locales ou des sujets
locaux ici sur l'immigration on voit
bien ce ne sont pas les collectivités
territoriales qui seront en première
ligne donc si on vient chercher le Sénat
en première lecture c'est bien qu'on
vient chercher cette sensibilité de
droite cette sensibilité LR qu'on ne
retrouvera pas à l'Assemblée nationale
donc je pense nécessairement que le
gouvernement escompte du Sénat qu'il
arrive lui-même à faire ce compromis qui
pourra ensuite être présenté à
l'Assemblée nationale et non inversement
c'est le gouvernement exactement donc
c'est aussi un message envoyé
de politique assumée en essayant
d'envoyer finalement la patate chaude en
quelque sorte au Sénat pour que lui-même
trouve le texte de compromis sur la
question la sensibilité de droite toute
la sensibilité de gauche c'est vrai
qu'il faut le redire en termes de
législation cette loi a de fortes
chances de ne pas changer grand chose au
droit existant quant au fait de savoir
si on doit passer par une noix ou par un
acte administratif sont quand même des
choses qui ne sont pas appelées par la
pure on va dire opportunité politique il
y a des choses qui méritent d'être
inscrit dans la loi et je crois
notamment même si on peine à savoir un
peu la consistance de ce projet de loi
immigration qu'il est question de quota
et ça ces choses là vous ne pouvez
évidemment pas les fixer par un acte
administ objectifs et il faut évidemment
que la représentation nationale se
prononcement législatif parce que ce
sont des sujets qui sont de vraies
questions démocratiques je disais qu'en
faire finalement le transformer ce des
investir le sujet de son fond réel et de
la manière dont il se pose dans le
quotidien dans la société française pour
en faire finalement un simple feuilleton
de la rentrée pour dire regarder moi je
suis plus à gauche regardez moi je suis
plus à droite ça ce n'est pas démocratie
LR ont comme argument aujourd'hui pour
refuser ce titre de séjour pour les
métiers en tension de dire mais en fait
en réalité ça se fait déjà de façon très
pratique dès régularisations au lieu
donc ne faisons pas ce projet de loi qui
est absolument ce projet de loi qui sera
perçu à leurs yeux comme un appel d'air
puisqu'on le fait déjà très concrètement
est-ce qu'il y a en terminale là-dessus
sur l'immigration et ensuite on va se
concentrer sur les relations à dire
personnelles d'Huma homme entre Gérard
Larcher et Emmanuel Macron mais est-ce
qu'il y a une pensée de gauche sur ce
thème aujourd'hui qui s'exprime sur le
thème de l'immigration il y a des
pensées de gauche c'est là la viv après
est-ce qu'elle passe le mur du son c'est
autre chose mais il y a indéniablement
diverses pensées et d'ailleurs c'est ce
qui crée une telle difficulté pour les
partenaires à se mettre d'accord il y a
une partie de la gauche qui a exercé au
gouvernement et qui n'a pas montré un
changement de paradigme majeur sur la
gestion de l'immigration et puis il y a
une gauche qui a plutôt été plébiscité
par les urnes ces dernières années qui
pousse pour des régularisations massives
une note un autre droit de l'accueil une
un vrai changement une dépoliarisation
de la gestion donc oui il y a des vrais
projets qui s'affrontent en la matière
et c'est précisément parce qu'il n'y a
pas de consensus à gauche comme à droite
sur le sujet que l'Assemblée nationale
était impossible en première lecture
parce qu'en fait on aurait on serait
tombé sur un texte qui n'aurait pas
recueilli suffisamment de de voix allez
on parle donc de des relations entre le
premier et le troisième personnage de
l'État Guillaume Daret ça n'a jamais été
simple non c'est même une relation
d'incompréhension et ce depuis le début
du premier mandat d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est ce qu'on me disait un ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement qui connaît
très bien les deux hommes vous avez côté
Gérard Larcher qui a la carrière d'élus
local qu'on lui connaît de
parlementaires de ministres qui aperçut
Emmanuel Macron comme une forme
disait-on je cite de parvenus sans
conviction Nicolas de vertébral
idéologique et puis de l'autre côté vous
avez Emmanuel Macron qui a eu le
sentiment de voir en Gérard Larcher la
représentation parfaite de l'ancien
monde qu'il était venu balayer et que
c'est soutien ne voulait plus voir après
2017 sur le fond ensuite il y a quand
même de vraies différences on le disait
Gérard Larcher il se veut le défenseur
des élus locaux on n'a pas le sentiment
qu'Emmanuel Macron en prend beaucoup
soin il se veut aussi le défenseur d'une
forme de sérieux budgétaire et
d'ailleurs taquet le président de la
République assez récemment et puis sur
cette question de l'immigration on a pu
voir aussi qu'ils avaient des positions
assez différentes tous les deux et puis
il y a deux événements qui ont
particulièrement marqué les relations
entre Emmanuel Macron et le président du
Sénat la première c'est en 2018
rappelez-vous la commission d'enquête
sur l'affaire Benalla deux personnes ont
été convoquées parmi d'autres ici il y a
eu déjà Patrick stroda qui a été le
directeur qui était le directeur de
cabinet d'Emmanuel Macron et puis Alexis
Kohler numéro 2 en quelque sorte dit-on
bras droit d'Emmanuel Macron et bien ça
ça a été perçu vraiment comme une forme
de provocation
de la part de l'Élysée qui n'a jamais
vraiment dirigérée que le Sénat puisse
faire cela et puis la deuxième chose
c'est cette petite phrase rappelez-vous
en mars 2022 de Gérard Larcher je cite
s'il n'y a pas de campagne la question
de la légitimité du gagnant se posera ça
non plus c'est pas passé à l'Élysée oui
effectivement parce que c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé juste après le la
victoire d'Emmanuel Macron sa réélection
on l'a vu avec ses opposants qui
intervenaient à l'antenne quelques
minutes après pour mettre en cause sa
légitimité est-ce qu'elles se sont quand
même un peu apaisées je vous dirais
qu'elle se sent normalisées déjà parce
que très clairement Emmanuel Macron n'a
pas vraiment eu le choix puisque depuis
juin 2022 il y a plus de majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale donc il
a été un peu contraint et forcé de fait
de revaloriser le Sénat et de fait de
revaloriser aussi le président du pour
effectivement tenter de construire ici
des compromis des consensus avec la
droite histoire de mettre la pression
ensuite avec la droite de l'Assemblée
nationale pour autant normalisation
aussi parce qu'un proche des deux hommes
me disait qu'ils sont peut-être un petit
peu différents de la première image
qu'on peut avoir Emmanuel Macron me
disait cet ancien ministre est
probablement beaucoup plus conservateur
que l'image moderne qu'il veut renvoyer
et Gérard lacher et peut-être un peu
plus moderne que l'image conservatrice
que beaucoup de Français en ont et puis
on voit très clairement que c'est
gagnant-gagnant parce qu'on disait
Gérard Larcher ça valorise le Sénat
salvalorise lui aussi dans un contexte
et dans un paysage politique où il y a
pas grand monde à droite pour autant de
là à l'imaginer à Matignon dans le cadre
d'une improbable coalition avec les
républicains on en est encore bien loin
ces mots d'ailleurs d'un proche
d'Emmanuel Macron en atteste le
président de la République a une
confiance très limitée en Gérard Larcher
il a l'impression qu'il ne lui dit pas
la même chose dans son bureau elle
Élisée et une fois qu'il est revenu ici
au Palais du Luxembourg merci beaucoup
pour pour toutes ces informations Jean
peut aussi faire jouer est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron finalement a été
obligé de changer d'avis de changer ou
d'attitude on va dire avec les corps
intermédiaires et avec le Parlement et
avec le Sénat ici Macron a l'habitude
d'être parfois un peu léger avec les
institutions en tout cas avec la
démocratie représentative et l'existant
d'un Parlement ou de corps intermédiaire
il est bien obligé de composer avec la
réalité institutionnelle on disait tout
à l'heure j'ai un marché et le président
du Sénat un sénat qui pèse plus parce
qu'il n'y a pas de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale et en Sénat qui
plus est représentent les élus locaux
qui ont beaucoup pété aussi malmenés par
au moins dans la perception qu'ils en
ont eu lieu par Emmanuel Macron
maintenant on voit bien que les
différentes tentatives d'Emmanuel Macron
de s'échapper de ce que sont nos
institutions n'ont jamais véritablement
fonctionné le format Saint-Denis
dernier format un mini
juridico-politique dont on voit pas bien
l'utilité à se reproduire
oui mais ça n'en fait pas moins des
ovnis
l'année dernière il y avait eu le CNR le
je sais même plus enfin bref de la
Conseil national
parce que ce sont des gadgets ce sont
des gadgets c'est quand même Macron
justement essaie de passer par-dessus
d'esprit nos institutions et que Gérard
Larcher lui pour le coup incarne et il
en a les moyens en terme de la
Constitution on l'a évoqué il l'a
rappelé au président de la République au
moment de l'affaire Benalla parce que je
pense que ça n'était pas ça ne se jouait
pas que par rapport à l'affaire Benalla
en soit c'était aussi une manière de
rappeler à l'Elysée qui a des
institutions et que le Parlement ça
existe et que dans une démocratie
l'exécutive doit respecter la séparation
des pouvoirs oui je suis d'accord avec
vous maisina on considère aussi que la
démocratie française c'est pas la seule
d'ailleurs nos démocraties occidentales
sont plutôt fatiguées ou peuvent à bout
de souffle on pourrait si on veut forcer
un peu le trait donc le rôle d'un
président de la République c'est
peut-être aussi d'essayer d'inventer de
nouvelles formes de concertation de
discussion démocratique alors c'est vrai
qu'on a dans la population française un
appel à de plus en plus de participation
on avait déjà ces murs tagués de Rick
pendant les gilets jaunes on essayait
d'avoir des référendums de tous les
types destitutions etc néanmoins c'est
vrai que canaliser cette volonté
populaire autour de vecteurs un peu
novateur comme ça peut être dangereux
pour un point au moins c'est que dans le
droit et dans n'importe quel type de
décision il y a de phases il y a la
consultation et la décision proprement
dite qui celle-ci ne peut être arbitrée
que par oui ou par non et en réalité
toutes les consultations qui ont été
lancées sont des consultations dans la
phase délibérative mais jamais dans la
phase de prise de décision et le oui ou
le nom on dirait qu'Emmanuel Macron
essaye parfois de de de s'en extraire or
au final la décision elle est toujours
proprement gouvernementale et donc c'est
une manière de jeter parfois un petit
peu de poudre aux yeux en faisant
participer sur la consultation et en
déconnectant complètement la décision
il y a ces deux phases et il faut mettre
la décision soit prise par quelqu'un qui
a une légit
institutionnelle mais après il y a un
sujet de représentation on peut inventer
tous les gadgets qu'on veut en termes
d'organes de consultation et autres si
les français se sentent orphelins de
représentation politique parce que les
parties ne savent plus véritablement
quoi dire du monde et c'est pour ça que
je vous disais tout à l'heure ce débat
regardez je suis de gauche parce que je
dis ça sur la loi de migration je suis
droite parce que je dis ça c'est quand
même le degré zéro de la réflexion
politique le sujet démocratique il est
là donc on pourra inventer tous les
gadgets qu'on veut et le fait
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'est pas voulu
reconstruire un parti qui ne l'a pas
fait il aurait pu le faire faire en
sorte que le pôle central qui l'incarne
soit une vraie matrice idéologique
finalement il n'est que l'incarnation du
statu quo je reviens aux relationnel on
va le dire entre Emmanuel Macron et
Gérard Larcher Florent Vaillot il y a
quand même un élément une date qu'il
faut rappeler c'est la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation c'est quand même perçu
quand on est la chambre des territoires
c'est c'est perçu comme quoi une sorte
de coup de poignard par gérardy à
l'époque mais c'est l'autonomie fiscale
des collectivités qui a été
considérablement
à moins de riz et c'est ensuite la
possibilité pour l'exécutif pour le
gouvernement de faire l'aumône aux
collectivités et on le voit sur la
dotation qui a été il y a eu une
concession de quelques centaines de
millions qui a été faite mais ça ne
couvre pas ce qui a été demandé aux
collectivités parce qu'il faut regarder
en fait en miroir les exigences qui ont
pesé via les préfets sur les
collectivités par exemple un détail qui
paraît tout à fait trivial mais pour
amener les seniors à être vaccinés à ne
pas l'état qui a organisé ça ils ont
demandé au mairies d'organiser alors que
ça n'est pas leurs compétences qu'elle
n'en avait pas les moyens que ça a été
compliqué donc quand on regarde cette
relation permanente entre l'État et les
collectivités on se rend compte qu'il y
a des demandes de croissantes et des
réalités des éléments qui financiers qui
baissent et autre exemple dans ce qui a
été dit par le Président de la
République sur
la taxe foncière il a annoncé que l'État
n'avait rien touché alors alors que la
base a augmenté du fait de l'État et que
des collectivités ont dû et expliquer
que cette augmentation était du fait de
l'État comment les maires ont-ils réagi
c'est la première fois qu'il y a une
vague d'indignation de la part des mères
sur Twitter qui ont annoncé mais non on
le présent peut pas mentir comme ça donc
sur cet aspect d'autonomie fiscal qui
revient très souvent c'est le noeud du
problème parce que c'est la capacité
d'action concrète de l'État sur les
territoires et des territoires sur les
électeurs et les collectivités
évidemment alors face à gérarchique
aujourd'hui il y avait différents
candidats des groupes de la gauche
sénatoriale mais pas de candidats des
groupes je simplifier Renaissance ou
horizon sur ce thème on écoute Mélanie
Vogel sénatrice écologie se représentant
les Français de l'étranger mis à part la
candidature de Gérard Larcher qui n'est
évidemment pas une surprise et l'issue
du vote n'est pas non plus une surprise
les seuls candidatures qui sont opposées
à la candidature de Gérard Larcher ce
sont les trois candidatures de gauche
nous remarquons donc que la majorité
présidentielle bien officiellement
officiellement dans l'opposition au
Sénat n'a pas présenté de candidatures
contre Gérard Larcher ça signifie que
manifestement je ne sais pas à quel
point il se considère réellement dans
l'opposition au Sénat mais manifestement
ils soutiennent la candidature de Gérard
Larcher puisque il ne présentent pas de
candidats contre lui votre avis
là-dessus unchainedine est-ce que c'est
une sorte de message c'est pas de
conciliation d'apaisement voyez par par
Emmanuel Macron et sa majorité c'est
compliqué de généraliser ce qui se passe
au Sénat comme un message politique
national parce que le Sénat a toujours
sous la Vème République et on peut même
remonter à la Troisième République une
identité tout à fait particulière en
termes d'affrontement de groupe
politique et aujourd'hui la centrisation
du groupe LR autour donc d'une
candidature commune de Gérard Larcher
signifie pas nécessairement que les LR
et la majorité arriveront à travailler
ensemble tout texte confondu néanmoins
c'est vrai que ça signifie en tout cas
qu'Emmanuel Macron et que ça majorité
essaye de tendre une main vers cette
nouvelle potentielle alliance LR ce qui
n'est pas forcément garantie je pense
vraiment que la loi immigration et le
budget
le font les deux épreuves du feu de
cette alliance des contraires parce que
nécessairement voter un budget c'est
plus ou moins faire partie des alliés
c'est là qu'on se compte donc on saura
s'il est LR vont vraiment aider la
majorité dans ces moments financiers
très compliqués bien sûr et c'est
peut-être aussi juste un argument public
mais la niveau gel évitez d'afficher une
situation de faiblesse des facto un
candidat présenté par ceux qui
soutiennent véritable la majorité de la
majorité mais bref groupe de soutien et
des groupes de soutien Emmanuel Macron
est recueilli peu de voix ça pour le
coup ça pouvait être perçu on a vu
d'ailleurs qu'Emmanuel Macron avait pris
la parole le soir des élections
sénatoriales c'était son intention mais
le résultat était celui là on a très peu
commenté les résultats en question qui
n'étaient pas bons pour le président de
la République peut-être son intention
Florent va dire là-dessus en tout cas
c'était peut-être pas moi j'avais
employé l'expression mauvaise manière
fait au Sénat on peut dire ça comme ça
c'est le minimum effectivement ne pas
présenter un candidat c'est pour éviter
la Bérézina parce que ça aurait été sans
doute le score le plus petit et surtout
des croissances et surtout il faut
regarder le score de Gérard Larcher il
manque des voix parce que quand on
accumule l'ensemble des groupes qui sont
censés avoir votés pour lui même s'il y
avait 28 d'absents on n'est pas au plein
donc je crois que au cabinet Gérard
Larcher ils savent faire de la politique
ils ont dû faire le compte et donc je
pense que l'absence de voix elle peut se
nicher uniquement chez le groupe de
François Patriat ou peut-elle chez
Claude Malleret mais ça me paraîtrait
quand même assez audacieux de sa part
donc je crois que le gouvernement a
quand même envoyé un petit message elle
est un tout dernier thème je récompense
on l'a souvent fait sur ce plateau mais
qu'on reparle de l'image du Sénat dans
l'opinion et ça nous permet de de
savourer une archive qui date du 24
septembre 2008 il y a 15 ans donc Gérard
Larcher remporte pour la première fois
devient pour la première fois président
du Sénat alors là on l'écoute c'est
juste après avoir remporté la primaire
UMP à l'époque donc on sait qu'il va
devenir président quelques jours plus
tard il parle de l'image de la Chambre
haute
il est devenu un exercice de mode de la
critiquer à partir de caricatures ou
d'information tronquées cela ne doit
plus être je m'y attacherai je prendrai
avec les instances compétentes de notre
assemblée toutes les décisions qui
paraîtront nécessaires je m'engage à la
transparence je ferai tout pour que dans
3 ans des Françaises et les Français
savent vraiment à quoi sert le Sénat je
ferai tout pour qu'ensemble chacun
d'entre nous surtout les rangs de cette
hémicycle nous soyons heureux et fiers
de notre action commune en étant 2008 24
septembre 2008 ça a pris sans doute un
peu plus de 3 ans uncharlet de bézina
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que par
exemple il y a une question qui se
posait c'était la question de l'utilité
ou même de l'existence du Sénat c'est là
plus personne la pose aujourd'hui je
serai moins optimiste malheureusement
c'est vrai que cette deuxième chambre
qui pourtant est la première parle de
chambre haute pour la désigner et
méconnu à son apport sa valeur ajoutée
dans le travail législatif qui pourtant
est réel et ça pas uniquement depuis que
les
projecteurs sont sur cette chambre bien
au contraire l'idée d'apporter déjà une
deuxième délibération en décalé
c'est-à-dire avec une vague politique
beaucoup moins forte que celle de
l'Assemblée nationale apporte beaucoup
au texte les différents textes
immigration même depuis 2006-2007 ont
beaucoup gagné à la lecture
constitutionnelle que fait le Sénat mais
j'ai le sentiment que la bataille dans
l'opinion gagne du galon en effet le le
Sénat c'est surtout illustré par le rôle
de contre-pouvoir ses commissions
d'enquête un peu offensives mais dès
lors qu'il travaille sur le fond des
textes on a le sentiment que ils se font
un petit peu dans le travail
parlementaire en même temps que
l'Assemblée nationale alors qu'il faut
le répéter l'originalité du travail du
Sénat tient aussi à sa composition à sa
manière de travailler et la chambre sert
vraiment à quelque chose il y a moins ou
plus de voix de grand leaders politiques
qui se posent la question de l'utilité
ou de l'existence du Sénat c'était un
peu ça le sens de ma question je pense
qu'on entendrait plus Lionel Jospin dire
que c'était une anomalie
démocratique ce qui était le cas à
l'époque qui avait soulevé une vraie
indignation oui parce qu'en fait
Emmanuel Macron ayant quand même
considérablement bousculé la vie
politique le Sénat est devenu le refuge
des vieux partis en fait l'ancien monde
si je voulais reprendre cette et donc
l'ancien monde n'a pas intérêt à
bousculer le Sénat prenons l'exemple des
socialistes un groupe de 64 sénateurs
socialistes c'est colossal c'est un
apport en termes de de bataillon de voix
pour les écologistes le groupe
sénatorial est supérieur au groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale et on pourrait
ainsi multipliser 145 134 députés les
sénateurs les républicains c'est enfin
c'est une manne extraordinaire donc je
pense que c'est malheureusement le fait
que
la politique des cartels a en quelque
sorte normalisé le Sénat mais en le
normalisant elle le met en danger parce
que je pense que c'est une forme de de
faux plat parce que plus le Sénat
devient une Assemblée nationale
raisonnable plus en réalité on va le
juger sur des critères politiques
traditionnels et c'est là que il
rencontrera des limites à mon sens merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vous dis à très bientôt
sur public